so i heard you took advantage of the
pandemic and you you did like some
at-home stuff you built something yeah
well partly because of stuff like that
you're so ashamed i felt shamed and i
was like i need a spot because i you
know we had no idea how long the
pandemic was going to go yeah so i was
like so i needed an office i needed it
in my backyard
and i wasn't sure how to do it so i
looked at youtube clips you can learn
everything on youtube dude
it blew my mind yes i learned everything
yeah and so i built a cabin i was doing
a lot of the zooms from there and you
built a cabinet you built that i built
that
what totally from youtube
everything from framingham like an hgtv
show
yeah i think people are like making
sourdough bread making like small bird
bot feeders or something you made an
actual cabin yeah it was great now what
you don't see in the photos is the
amount of ants and spiders that live in
there yeah and how hot it gets you just
have to pretend you're camping that's
what it is it's camping non-stop but i
put it up it was great it's been great
and then when summer hit it was the
first time i'm like oh yeah this is a
sauna oh i built an ann's house
yeah i thought texas was hot the valley
here is like a different level of i hate
my life
yeah yeah but what i will say from doing
a
little zoom in there to this
this is so nice
i think it's a recipe you did that it
was really fun
do your kids love that my kids would go
nuts over that you know they don't
because i mean the trick is just throw a
couple spiders and ants in a spot and
kids have no interest
so now i know what to do yes
so i really i was like okay so i built
line them up in front of my room and
everything you like one big spider
just to deter them
that's right this is good advice
[Music]